woman that Layla and I are friends with
very successful business owner had a boy
toy with her he was like aren't you
concerned about overtraining and I was
feeling a little pissy that day and I
said bro once you start looking like you
work out you can worry about over
training until that point
you don't need to worry about over
training I was being a little bit mean
but he did remember it he did change the
way he trained and he did gain muscle
afterwards so I felt okay about it your
ability to recover from working out
itself is trainable so when you do more
volume your ability to withstand volume
your work capacity increases and so to
the same degree people are like I feel
burnt out the thing is is that you
either die or you adapt that's it in the
Fitness World you either die get injured
or adapt and since you're probably not
going to die you really just need to
make sure that you don't get injured and
if you don't get injured and you don't
die you get better